something that I work towards but I knew
for a long time in that race that I was
going to run world record and I was
doing it in London with the support of
my home club and it was a really special
moment how much does it mean to you 14
years on you still have the world record
and well is clinging on it's clinging on
by oh by fingernails and that's what you
expect I mean sitting watching the
London Marathon watching Mary Kotani run
an attack it's so strongly of course I
was nervous because nobody wants to
really wants to lose a record but that
could finally happened to Paula
radcliffe's world where called marathon
time of 2 hours and 15 minutes set in
2003 not replaced by a faster woman that
under proposals to scrap all athletic
world records set the for 2005 when
blood and urine tests came to team there
is a part of you that is hurt by it
definitely because it feels like we're
kind of being thrown in the bin almost
during our careers refer to compete
against people that we've heavily
suspected or known we're cheating we've
lost out probably on moments medals
career earnings as well all of those
times we've lost out and now to lose out
again just because of the actions of
people who chose to cheat European
Athletics believe the move would clean
up the image of a sport damaged by
doping do you think there's still a
problem in terms of public trust in the
sport and yes I I do I think the the
events of the last couple of years have
kind of really hit the sport hard and I
think we have to restore that
credibility and I love the sport but I
won't just let my records be swept aside
as collateral damage she's not the only
top British athlete who could be
affected Jonathan Edwards triple jump
record is still the farthest and Colin
Jackson's indoor hurdles time has never
been beaten but all could be relegated
we want to ensure the public regain
their trust in athletics over a million
members of the British public will
actually you know entered the stadium
behind me for the world attended
Championships here in August and we want
them to actually believe what they're
watching to understand exactly what
they're watching and to enjoy the sport
again the controversial proposal has
been welcomed by Seb Coe head
the athletic governing body the IWA f
but still needs to be officially
ratified it must feel like a slanting
load yeah yeah I think that's the
hardest thing it should go by sport
moving on and by somebody surpassing
that performance not by just being swept
aside SAR HBGary Sky News